converse but you're not play hotter King
City mom take a look at this haunted you
press remember so this game must be nowt
on seemed actually for a while but they
just came out with a new episode let's
[ __ ] some pants man I think we should
playing hard because you know I'm a
pretty hardcore gamer a zebras no you
know I'm finished Dark Souls I'm
actually sick now what the hell
hey man see the cartoon ought to be too
heavy slow this old bridge yes I can see
that hot-diggity Bane Mara myself to
light up the interior a bit and start a
fire in the fireplace soon as the
rightful owner you'll have to take care
of it yourself
alright let it be I ship them so much
goddamn I'm [ __ ] forest to this
mansion Paris finalmente so no Adubato
aravaan alright where the hell are we
what is that little guy go so far this
isn't really scary
alright god damn oh you installed self
opening doors I was on my favorite
what's going on here
it's just wait away what are you doing
it's a ball man get over it dude what
are you doing what yo Rudy it what it
what it labelling me oh oh ha ha ha I
don't think is I supposed to do that oh
my god oh my god what the [ __ ]
and yet oh and yeah
that is the most [ __ ] up thing man
what okay I guess I'll go on without
ever it is I have to admit that I did
not expect such a mess but a space it's
amazing that's what they said about my
battle yeah go fix your eye okay helliya
palace sure hello glue eating food I'll
be waiting I'll be skating I'll be
typing Ryder Braden fight my someone
started talking to me right away
shut up this place is that dull oh I
keep seeing stuff in the dark and it's
scaring me
hi shares how are thou good really hard
to see what's going on you know some
kind of lantern I would not object to
having all right what do we got I pick
stuff off but I can't do anything okay
oil lamp I don't even have an oil lamp
give me my [ __ ] name now can I
play the piano hole can apply the P up
ya know before you go I just want to
play the piano for you girl I just wanna
rock it well with the booty slap and
girl huh I love me some wood slapping
love me some slack and to the left to
the right that's all right baby alright
that's a great dead plant those are my
favorite that's a nice letter why don't
I just pick up one of these candles and
just [ __ ] part I mean like why not
I like that said Jerry Jerry said yo hey
man I missed you how you been wait who's
dead Jerry yeah it's fine look Jerry's
fine alright well let's pick up this
Lantern how do I use the light pin that
is right hi did you happen to kill that
guy with a freaky eye and no I'm not
saying that just cause it rhymes no I'm
not saying that just cuz it rhyme hey
you barely even know me
you're the one with blood on you how
would I kill him I wasn't even here
oh now you just be mean my dress is way
prettier than yours
okay don't even think god I'm good I'm
good oh here's that well you win this
round [ __ ] what a great way to die just
speech but in the [ __ ] bathtub I'll
try and do the same if I ever go alright
what do you do if a guy dies and you're
alone in the forest
well you jump down the toilet no you
can't do that Jerry Jerry don't whatever
you just [ __ ] did don't [ __ ] do it
okay cuz it freaks the [ __ ] out of me
okay
god damn what Duff oh oh so many of you
that's really nice
god damn okay you are they better you or
the dress better I gotta go I gotta go
bro what how do you fly man how do you
even do anymore I don't like this no bat
oh god they're [ __ ] everywhere [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
okay good thing they can't open doors
that's a greatest weakness back shied
say okay
nice that's convenient all right father
we got here we have a little king space
the show that's very useful very very
useful thank you
no I'm not got not going back in there
it will seem that I'm going back in
there
hello ich bin boots don't tell me okay I
know we have our differences but that
doesn't mean we can't hang out okay
what is that coming from that's creepy
man oh we can go in here now that's nice
I'll it's funny to go in here it's a
very nice place
all right cosy I like the color choice I
like Jerez ask - it's not just thin and
it's not too thick you know you know I'm
saying yeah I'm that's called a
complementary it's like the opposite of
killing it Slendy man so he's the one
behind this huh well [ __ ] still with the
Slendy [ __ ] how many times do I got
to beat you boo jab bloody feet done ok
ok ok na hai hai rude
hey dear guys that's cool that's cool
alright you are kind of freaking me out
a little bit so I'm just gonna I'm just
go back to you I'm just gonna go up here
the staff in my own ha no I never watch
these days does it man how many stairs
this day god damn it's like this game
things I have nothing better to do
alright I'm tired
Oh what what do you think how do you
think why I have came here
about it what's the point why would you
even care
yes I am no longer how could you use
your why I like a song like the new Lady
gaga what is his say here okay they're
saying it's bad to turn on suppose this
moonwalk okay I get it I'm supposed to
moonwalk away from them how do I refill
my lamp you know if I could [ __ ] see
what would happen that would be great Oh
what I have enough what nice what nice
Isis man why well now you just [ __ ] I
don't think that was supposed to happen
I have an axe what do you do with an axe
man
oh you guys are all line up and [ __ ]
that's cool I like lines oh yeah why
thank you ma'am
polite ooh [ __ ] oh cool I'm
getting sacrificed well [ __ ] me you need
I'm sick of you and your what okay you
need to stop whatever you'll be doing
don't like it huh I don't have a lot of
flashlight battery okay I'm somebody I'm
Kraven Manor a little too much
I think but hey I like it anyway okay we
can go back now cool cool they're not
gonna [ __ ] with me anymore
I'm too cool for school seriously I'm
not cool too cool for anything so what
am I supposed to use this axe oh this
could be it hot chop hahaha [ __ ] yeah Oh
can I go now oh my god cool why can't I
just dual wield that would make me so
much happier let me do all women as all
horror tropes we shall go upstairs and
see if everything is okay everything is
okay what watches hat what
[ __ ] don't do that man you scare me for
no reason at all don't like II write
what we got we gotta see if a key what's
happening over there the arrow points to
warhead how convenient
wonder what how the arrow tells me to go
here thanks Sarah oh thanks guys you
know what you have a brother aren't you
yeah you can touch my ass if you
watching hi hi hi god damn you [ __ ]
perps god damn who do you think I am
some kind of [ __ ]
god damn you [ __ ] I'm moonwalking
moonwalking it's all part okay I am
action I'm stuck well that [ __ ] is
coming closer
oh god damn this is [ __ ] scary man
stop it what are you doing stop i watch
alright so now it doesn't even load what
a great way to end an episode viewers
enjoy watching regardless leave a like
if you enjoyed watching maybe i'll try
to fix this it's a scar comrade today
zebras next one
as always yeah
you